je m'appelle Dominique Marte je
travaille la peinture depuis que j'ai 14
15 ans j'ai été diplômé de l'école abvec
peinture de Paris et jusqu'à 18 20 ans
j'ai fait des des études de de peinture
de dessin d'ancre d'aquarel j'ai arrêté
temporairement parce que à l'âge de 20
25 ans on pense ça s'amusit qu'à peindre
et mais ayant toujours gardé des
affinités et des relations avec des
grands peintres post impressionnistes
comme pierrechard et Jacques bissou et
le déclic s'est refait avec la peinture
quand je me suis installé à La Réunion
en 2005 et là nous sommes en 2016 ça
fait donc 11 12 ans que je printe
passionnément les paysages de la
Réunion croyant surtout la peinture à
l'huile appliquée à la brosse et au
couteau avec des inclusions de feuilles
de cuivre quelquefois des petits
coquillages que j'ai ramassé le matin
sur les plages de
l'Hermitage la peinture pour moi est
très importante parce qu'elle permet de
transcrire des émotions et des
atmosphères et si je peux faire partager
mon émotion avec les personnes qui
aiment mes tableaux et bien le but sera
réalisé I